[Musique]
au zimbabwe
là on armées chargé j'espère bien
il y en a trop
je vous déclare mari et là
toi et ta bande de salopards six cordes
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on paye c'est m
trois kilos de plutonium pur peuvent
changer les équilibres du monde imagine
ce que 5 tonnes pour un verre
[Musique]
tu vas avoir besoin de plus d'hommes si
tu veux t'en sortir vivant je suis de
retour
tu ne peux pas laisser le contenu de ce
qu'offre tomber en de mauvaises mains
c'est quoi le plan les traquer les
trouver les tuer
[Musique]
en avant
comment t'as fait ça
avec mon porte bonheur
bon
ma chaussure est plus grande que cette
question tout ce qui bouge
[Musique]
on craint faire sur la correspondance ou
que si
[Musique]
notre falloir nouvel avion